linear a difficult match against Hikaru
Nakamura in a difficult game today did
you expect him to transition early on
into this type of end game and try to
pile on the pressure in this type of
situations uh yeah I mean I I thought
it's possible that he placed this line I
mean he played it before but I thought
it's such a solid line that I shouldn't
have too many problems
in fact I think I got a good position
um I I played this line against washir
in in Romania last year in the ground
but yeah overall it's a very solid
position I think I was doing quite quite
okay until the moment when I play
yeah all this looks fine when Rook d8
but here I missed that yeah I thought I
was just a few moves back when I took on
E3 Knight E3 of course my plan was to
yeah take on E3 take on E3 I thought
Knight Bishop B4 of course but then I I
saw Bishop E4 got it yeah and because if
yeah if if takes or we should do one
then I'm fine but but Knight C4 suddenly
oh it creates some unbalance in the
position because I have to play Bishops
in seven or uh Bishop takes E4 Pawn
takes and I didn't want to allow this
like I wanted to keep the structure to
symmetry I thought it's more safe but
then I was hesitating between a few
different moves and finally I just got
worse uh yeah Rook D1 Bishop F5 I think
it's it's a bad decision I should be two
supposedly was the better he should be
two Rook D2 I was thinking about
Euphoria attacks takes and Rook C2 I
wasn't sure
I mean of course I have yeah two Bishops
and maybe white can play B3 T4
immediately C4 at some point but it's a
similar situation to to the one we got
in the game because yeah take stakes and
before yeah I wasn't maybe before is
interesting I was expecting something
along the lines of B3 and C4 or maybe A5
first and then B3 C4
and I thought it's quite quite
unpleasant for black here so I didn't
like my position at all
um
but uh yeah before actually giving his
Bishop pair with Bishop yeah because I
want to play Knight D6 now so if B5 I
think not 96 but takes on B5 a B96 and
maybe I'm kind of holding Aya with 94
and born on B5 this week on C3 and so on
so yeah I mean but overall I was happy
to see Bishop takes at five and and
because then I and you found this nice
movement yeah so like in the game with
levonne I'm playing against this double
F pawns uh this time two or three but
yeah I think this is pretty pretty dead
here because once you close the position
it's very difficult for white to open
yeah on the queen side yeah a difficult
uh game uh difficult match tomorrow you
will be having the white pieces what is
the general strategy yeah well it's uh
better situation than than the one today
so at least I have one game with white
I'll of course
um try to to press
um and and see what happens guys any
questions for a year good luck tomorrow
uh linear